okay let's talk about the total lack of
coherence and logic behind Donald
Trump's multiple explanations about that
New York Times report which explained
hey you know what
in 1995 Donald Trump reported a 19 I'm
sorry I 916 million dollar loss on his
1995 taxes he initially said that that
makes him smart right so let's really go
through this in a logical manner you see
this 916 million dollar loss on Trump's
1995 tax returns potentially Donald
Trump could have used that loss to then
offset federal taxes he would have had
to pay in up to the following 18 years
and maybe not paid federal taxes for
nearly two decades following this we
don't know that because we don't have
Donald Trump's taxes we just don't have
them we don't know the initial reaction
from Trump when he was accused of not
paying federal taxes by Hillary Clinton
in the first debate was to say that
makes me smart I'll remind you what that
looked and sounded like nothing in taxes
because the only years that anybody's
ever seen we're a couple of years when
he had to turn them over to state
authorities when he was trying to get a
casino license and they showed he didn't
pay any federal income tax so yeah so
that's Trump's initial spin I have no
doubt that those are his true feelings
Trump thinks he's pretty clever because
he's figured out a way not to pay taxes
now not paying taxes doesn't make you
smart it makes you a freeloader that's
exactly what it makes you in a literal
sense that that's okay doesn't play too
well with voters clearly so Donald Trump
has been spinning it a different way he
now is saying that his inside knowledge
of the tax code and how to game it
actually makes him qualified to be
President here's a tweet that Donald
Trump sent out recently where he said I
know our complex tax laws better than
anyone who has ever run for prayer
and am the only one who can fix them
okay well that's something to think
about at least right Trump has taken
advantage of these tax loopholes for the
rich and he knows exactly how they could
be changed and fixed what's the problem
with that statement well the problem is
we've seen Donald Trump's tax plan and
it would do absolutely nothing to fix
these problems Trump's tax plan wouldn't
close the loophole that would have
allowed him to avoid paying taxes for
many years Trump's tax plan would by and
large give the largest windfalls to the
highest earners including people in the
top 0.1% and Donald Trump's tax plan
would repeal the estate tax which would
only affect the tiny minority of the
wealthiest people and families in the US
and by the way an analysis from an
organization called Third Way concluded
that Donald Trump's own family would be
one of that teeny tiny percentage of
families that would benefit from Donald
Trump repealing the estate tax to the
tune by the way of a seven billion
dollar benefit if Donald Trump is going
to make the argument that by having
taken advantage of these laws himself he
will know how to fix them he needs to
make a proposal to fix them his actual
tax proposal would make these laws even
more favorable to the richest of the
rich so this does not pass the laugh
test and then we always get to the
question why do people who will never
ever ever even come close to being in a
position to benefit from these laws why
would they ever support someone like
Donald Trump well I think part of it is
the idea that they probably believe I to
one day may be rich enough to benefit
from this type of nonsense statistically
speaking most of those people will not
and some of it may be that they're
influenced by these ideas of hey he's
successful and he is taking advantage of
the law as he sees it and he is going to
make the law even better for himself and
because he's rich
he's good because that's something that
there's a lot in American culture that
is tied into if you figured out a way to
make a ton of money you are good and you
should be applauded on
fortunately we know that that is not
true I've talked about how people of all
ages but particularly Millennials are
owning cars less and participating more
in the sharing economy and one of the
more popular options is Zipcar which
gets you a car when you want it when you
need it they offer all sorts of cars
SUVs hybrids whatever you need it
includes insurance and it includes gas
you just pay for the time that you
actually use the car and you can reserve
the car online from your smartphone over
the phone then you unlock it with your
zip card each car share member reduces
their personal co2 emissions by between
1100 and 1600 pounds per year for our
audience
Zipcar is offering $25 a free driving
credit if you sign up at join zip car
comm slash david support our show reduce
your carbon emissions and you're
spending on cars sign up at join zip car
comm slash David